our main story tonight concerns the
corona virus you know the thing you have
to regularly convince your parents still
exists oh you went to a Shoney's did you
who else was there the whole town Wow
please stay inside you extremely fragile
maniacs in recent weeks there's been a
series of alarming spikes all over the
country but one particular kind of place
as we getting hit especially hard
prisons are seeing an alarming spike
data collected by the New York Times
shows the number of inmates infected is
above 68,000 that's doubled over the
last month Prison deaths tied to the
virus have risen by 73 percent since
mid-may the five largest known clusters
of the virus are in correctional
institutions yeah it's true the five
largest clusters of coronavirus are
correctional institutions which is so
terrible it sounds like an announcement
produced by some sort of bad news
generator that spits out random
sentences like Confederate statue inks
10 episode deal with kwibi or tick-tock
hamster charged with four counts of
vehicular manslaughter or sean hannity
dating Ainsley Earhardt one of those is
real and it's the worst one and the
facts the corona virus is rampaging
through prisons and jails is especially
alarming given that there are 2.2
million people being held in them across
the country and inmates are generally a
group with higher health risks between
1999 and 2016 the number of people 55 or
older in prison has increased 280
percent and people inside jails are more
likely to be immunocompromised with
chronic health issues like diabetes and
hypertension so this is an immensely
vulnerable population and inmates very
much know that as these advocate
explains
I personally am in contact with more
than 300 people who are incarcerated
they report to me day in and night out
Lois this is like me standing in the
middle of i-95 in New York right in the
middle of the road and cars zipping by
me at a hundred and seventeen miles an
hour in both directions and it's just a
matter of time before I'm hit with this
thing yeah it mates feel like it's just
a matter of time before they get sick
which is terrible because we don't
punish people by giving them diseases
take me for instance I don't have Lyme
disease because of my 2008 public
intoxication charge no I have it because
those deer knew had a party back
then I've got to be honest I miss that
crew so tonight let's talk about a few
things why the corona virus has spread
so rapidly behind bars
the impact that has on absolutely
everyone and what we can and should be
doing about it and just as a quick
refresher jails are where people are
detained while awaiting trial or held
for minor sentences while prisons
typically hold people who've been
convicted and are serving sentences of
more than a year and whether you're in a
jail or a prison you are probably in a
facility that is in no way built to cope
with a crisis like this because it's
basically impossible to keep six feet
apart in a tiny cell as Ted Koppel found
out a few years ago confinement and
social distancing are mostly
incompatible you don't have can only
move at a time like a phone this is we
have to turn sideways right it's hard to
practice social distancing when you live
in what's basically a closet with two
beds and a toilet in fact I'd argue you
can't practice most things under those
circumstances apart from games like
let's try not to accidentally hug each
other and who can poop the quietest and
incidentally the correct answer to that
last question is Blake Lively she poops
the quietest that is simply a fact and
some of the steps authorities have taken
to deal with this problem are
ridiculously small as this worries
mother of one prisoner explains they're
being locked down for like twenty three
and a half hours a day they get to come
out for like ten minutes and use the
phone and you you know take a shower and
then go back in and those small cells
there telling them sleep from head to
foot but I mean even from head to foot
if you're in a small cell it doesn't
make a difference
exactly and that's probably not
comforting for a mother to hear is it oh
don't worry mom all prisoners are
instructed to sleep head to foot and
when they're awake we tell them to
breathe in opposite directions we're
pretty sure we've got this covered
then there's the simple issue of soap as
everyone knows by now a key way to
protect against the corona virus is by
regularly washing your hands
in jails and prisons Soph maybe rationed
or not available at all
and if inmates need more they may have
to buy it from the commissary and as
we've covered before on this show
despite doing most of the work to keep
prisons and jails running inmates only
make pennies for their labor in fact
some facilities have even posted signs
about the importance of hand washing
but then continued to charge inmates for
access to soap and multiple prisoners
have felt they needed to go out of their
way to try and alert the world to this
dangerous shortage this is what they
gave us there's less danger CELTA worth
the stay clean they wash their hands and
and this for Harry two weeks they
are not giving us hand sanitizer they're
not giving us episode this is the soap
dish that's in arm after all it's just
pieces of soap that everybody gotta wash
their hands with we have to soap
dispensers but sometimes on a weekend
the soap runs out that is clearly awful
they should always be enough soap and I
know if you wanted to do a decent parody
of me you wouldn't be too far off if you
slapped on a suit faked a British accent
and went around shrieking there should
always be enough soap but that doesn't
make it any less true does it there
should always be enough soap and
especially at that last facility at
which as of April about 80% of its
residents had contracted the virus and
is by no means just cleaning products
that are scarce PPE
is in such short supply that it's led to
prisoners wearing socks on their hands
when they use the phone which might be
the saddest sock puppet ever and testing
has been so lacking that inmates can't
be confident about who does and doesn't
have the virus and on top of that if
someone does show symptoms they're often
placed in solitary confinement because
prisons have nowhere else to quarantine
them and it's not a great incentive for
inmates to come forward if your policy
is basically look just tell us that
you're sick and we'll put you in this
special punishment hole and when you
take all of this together
the close quarters the lack of basic
protections and the uncertainty about
the spread of a potentially deadly virus
it's honestly no surprise that tensions
can hit a breaking point
just after 3 o'clock Thursday afternoon
an inmate took cell phone video inside
the C block of the Lansing Correctional
Facility yeah I mean anyone is thinking
that that's an extreme response I'd
simply ask this what else are they
supposed to do what other bargaining
chip two prisoners have at their
disposal right now this is actually
being a bit of a recurring theme lately
but I'll say it again if it takes the
destruction of property for a system to
pay attention to human lives then we are
in a dark place and I know that
if you are fortunate enough to have
little to no familiarity with the prison
system it can be easy to ignore this
problem and that issue is actually
reflected by some in local government in
California when an outbreak in a Santa
Barbara prison made it difficult for
that County to meet the state standards
for reopening local officials proposed
simply not counting the prisoners with a
county spokesman saying the individuals
are not out in the community so it's
really a whole separate population which
is the kind of thing you should only
really be saying if there was a corona
virus outbreak in Atlantis look they
don't even breathe air down there
they're really a whole separate
population and the director of the
Arkansas Department of Health trying to
put an even more optimistic spin on the
prison outbreaks that they were having
there these are high-risk settings we're
covered 19 can spread very easily very
rapidly but they're also closed systems
and they don't necessarily represent the
situation in Arkansas in general a
fortunate thing about that kind of
setting is that it's it's not that hard
to contain it because people aren't
going out and about they're not they're
not leaving the prison ok even if
prisons and jails were closed systems
which they are very much not for reasons
we're about to get into it's weird to
call outbreaks of a deadly virus
fortunate just because they're confined
to one place the news didn't go insane
covering balloon
boy because they were stoked it was just
one boy he contained in a homemade
balloon careening through the sky no it
was treated as an emergency because
there was a chance he was gonna
die thankfully of course there turned
out to be zero boys in that balloon as
it was later revealed to be a hoax
pulled off by the boy's parents in order
to make the family who had appeared on
the reality show wife swap more
marketable to the media and holy
remember when Balloon Boy was the
craziest story you had to worry about
2009 truly was a simpler time to be
alive and look for the record people are
absolutely going out and about from
prisons because not everyone in a prison
is in prison there are around 440 5000
non inmate staff personnel working in
prisons across the country and those
workers have reported over 9,000
coronavirus cases we might as well be
handing them coronavirus gift bags as
they leave work every day and head back
out into the community and staff
bringing the virus in and out of
facilities isn't the only way that it
can spread it can hop from prison to
prison as inmates are transferred around
and it can also get out into the
community when sick prisoners are
treated at local hospitals particularly
in rural areas where hospitals can
easily get overwhelmed and that is
before we get into jails where there is
a constant churn of people moving in and
out in a typical week more than 200,000
people are booked into jails across the
country and another 200,000 walk out so
outbreaks in prisons and jails can
easily spread to the larger community in
fact one study suggested that as of
mid-april more than 15% of all
documented coronavirus cases in Illinois
could be linked to just one facility the
Cook County Jail
and while the jail strongly disputes
those findings there were activists who
saw the danger signs early on like this
man who was warning people back in March
as of right now Cook County Jail is a
virtual petri dish Cook County Sheriff
Tom dart
he is the captain of a cruise ship Wow a
death cruise ship look cruise ships are
already comfortably bad enough without
bringing death into the equation it's
like if our parent company
branded themselves as genocide AT&T guys
guys I don't know how you could possibly
make a worse experience than the one
that you're already providing people the
point here is coronavirus doesn't stay
behind bars it travels easily which
actually brings us to our final question
what can we do well realistically we
need to be getting as many people out of
prisons and jails as possible which is
frankly something we should be doing
anyway but right now we really don't
have much of a choice the fewer people
in these facilities the easier it will
be for those people to socially distance
the fewer staff you'll need on-site and
the lower your demand for PPE but of
course when releasing inmates this is
the response all right first off
taxidermied George Lucas you seem to be
struggling to think of more than one
kind of criminal there burglar thief
identity forger those are all just
synonyms for stealing what about all the
other criminals in Texas like the man
who posed as a boat Oh
a rogue volunteer broke into someone's
home and took a popsicle or the man who
was forced to return three thousand
dollars in prize money for cheating in
bass fishing contests or even Thorman
who drank wine out of a Pringles can
while driving an electric cart around a
Walmart parking lot for several hours
Texas has a vibrant crime scene with a
lot more variety than your frankly
giving it credit for
an i dog you that there are some people
we have no excuse for not releasing
immediately especially those awaiting
trial in jail who pose little risk to
public safety and are only there because
they couldn't afford to post bail and
look I am NOT saying that every person
who's let out due to the corona virus
will behave perfectly no one can say
that and I'm sure that you will see
people on TV excitedly citing isolated
cases of people who were released and
then did bad things you'll see that on
shows like crime porn for old White's
with Laura Ingraham or they're coming
for you
with a human squash court
but on balance the risks of carefully
letting people out are vastly outweighed
by the risks of leaving everyone in
sight as for prisons the bare minimum we
should do is release offenders who've
served the majority of their sentences
particularly the immunocompromised and
the elderly those groups are at high
risk for the virus and the elderly are
also a very low risk to RIA vent you can
also place certain prisoners on furlough
basically pausing their sentence and
having them return to finish it once the
pandemic is under control or you can
place them under house arrest and at the
national level to his and I cannot
believe I'm going to say this credit
attorney general part released a DOJ
memo instructing federal prisons to
reduce their populations which sounds
like a great idea in theory but to date
they've only done that by around three
percent which is even worse than the
typical state prison because they've
reduced their population by just 5
percent and that's simply not enough and
I know this might put you in the
uncomfortable situation of having to
argue on behalf of people that you might
not find inherently sympathetic take the
case of one federal prisoner who pushed
hard to be released a judge has rejected
convicted pharmaceutical executive
martin shkreli's requests to be let out
of a prison to research a coronavirus
treatment the presiding judge noted that
probation officials viewed that claim as
the type of quote delusional behavior
that led to his conviction in the first
place
yeah martin shkreli the farmer bro tried
to get released to home arrest so that
he could work on developing a cure for
the corona virus presumably so he called
it Rhona juice and then sell it for five
thousand percent more than it should
cost and he was denied and when you hear
that you might think good that guy
and generally yeah that guy
but in this instance despite the fact
that martin shkreli is an
attention-starved
tree frog who clearly wasn't held enough
as a tadpole and despite his reasoning
for why he should be released being
complete i don't want him to
contract the virus and potentially die
from it I don't want that for anyone
none of us should and yet right now
millions of Americans are currently
stuck in truly desperate straits and
vastly disproportionately people of
color and some prisoners have become so
desperate they will risk punishment to
try and get anyone in the outside world
to pay attention to their situation
just watch this prisoner openly using a
contraband cell phone which he knows
will lead to consequences to try and
raise an alarm this over
here dying from Khurana they got this
one while wrong they literally
leaving us and her to death this is
Aaron Campbell he's an inmate at FCI
Elton's below security federal prison in
Ohio he's using a contraband cell phone
and he knows he's gonna get in trouble
for making this video so I was like
you you know try to keep this one the
farm situation like a book like this is
serious it's fun
everybody in this man and he's
like what the you want me to do my
man is bit no I absolutely do not want
that and I have to tell you the
authorities at that prison have said
that the men in that video were actually
completely fine and neither was sick
although you should also know that by
the government's own count at that one
low security institution more than six
hundred inmates have tested positive for
coronavirus and nine have died and if
you're wondering how that prisoner was
doing he's reportedly been in solitary
since that video went viral in early
April and he wrote a letter to a
reporter saying that officials told him
he wouldn't face additional discipline
if he issued a statement saying the
video was fake
a request he then refused which is
incredibly brave and that's coming from
me a man who was never missed an
opportunity to say I'm sorry for
literally anything so at this point it's
worth asking what the are we doing
here particularly during this pandemic
but also in general because there's
obviously a much larger discussion to be
had about how millions of people ended
up incarcerated in the first place and
whether or not prisons even work which I
would argue they absolutely do if your
only goal is to have a lot of people in
prison the fact is we should be
depopulating prisons and jails as
quickly as we can right now and I know
how that sounds because we were all
raised hearing that you shouldn't do the
crime if you can't do the time but in
our current system you're never just
being sentenced to time you've been sent
us to a lifetime of social stigma futile
job interviews and
blocks to necessities like housing all
of that is immoral enough there is
frankly no reason whatsoever we should
now also be sentencing people to die
from a virus because that's not justice
it's neglect and it really matters
because as much as we'd like to pretend
that incarcerated people are a separate
population than not whatever they've
done they are still members of our
society and if this horrific year has
taught us one thing is that we are all
on this death cruise-ship together
you